what do a back tattoo pulp fiction and
donald glover have in common they're all
easter eggs you might have missed in the
mcu
it was the unexpected success of iron
man that gave marvel studios the jump
start it needed that said it also helped
that the filmmakers sneaked in little
references here and there to a larger
universe this includes a prop that only
eagle-eyed viewers caught the shield of
world war ii hero captain america it's
partially constructed and sitting idly
on tony stark's work desk in a 2010
interview with mtv director john favreau
explained that the movie's inclusion of
the iconic symbol was nothing more than
a visual gag at least at first he
explained an industrial light and magic
artist put it in there as a joke to us
for our cinesync sessions when we're
approving visual effects they liked it
enough that they kept it in the film's
final cut
in the incredible hulk emil blonsky
receives a special serum that transforms
him into the abomination a monster
intended to be halt's physical match the
container holding the serum bears a
label attributing its development to a
certain dr reinstein a name familiar to
long-time captain america readers dr
reinstein was actually a fake name used
by dr abraham erskine the man who
developed the super soldier formula that
turned the scrawny steve rogers into
america's mightiest champion
interestingly the final cut of the
incredible hulk could have featured more
than a passing reference to the captain
had things turned out the way the
director originally intended a deleted
scene actually included a cameo of the
star-spangled avengers frozen body
preserved underneath the arctic ice
aside from introducing new heroes black
widow and war machine iron man 2 also
delved deeper into the avengers
initiative exploring how it would be
executed while emphasizing that stark
may not be a good addition to the
project prone to self-destructive
tendencies i was dying i mean please and
aren't we all
interestingly the scene where fury
delivers the not-so-good news to stark
contains an early reference to the
existence of a hero who would eventually
fight alongside the avengers the black
panther the sequence features the two
men sitting down in a covert location
and discussing black widow's assessment
of stark besides stark and fury are some
shield holographic screens that depict a
map of the world with certain locations
marked the marker that certainly got a
lot of attention though is the one that
pointed to a seemingly secret location
in africa the technologically advanced
vibranium-rich nation of wakanda
in the scene where thor is proclaimed by
his father odin as asgard's next king we
see their sworn enemies the frost giants
making their way through the palace
walls and into the vault where precious
artifacts are kept by the all father
seeking to obtain the casket of ancient
winters they struck a deal with thor's
trickster brother loki that allowed them
to sneak into the palace undetected
however when the invaders attempt to
take the relic the destroyer comes to
life and takes them down in the chaos
that follows the infinity gauntlet is
shown for a brief moment on screen
however as hella casually revealed in
thor ragnarok the gauntlet in odin's
vault was a counterfeit this throwaway
line of dialogue was meant to address a
massive plot hole that was created when
avengers age of ultron showed the
gauntlet in the possession of thanos all
along
set during the second world war the
first captain america movie told the
tale of how a scrawny bullied kid from
brooklyn was gifted with a superhuman
physique to match his super heroic heart
initially deemed too expensive and risky
to send out into actual combat captain
america soon took the lead in fighting
hitler's men wait a minute an american
adventurer in an iconic costume going up
against german forces if that sounds
familiar to you perhaps you've seen
raiders of the lost ark in case that
connection isn't enough there's a line
of dialogue uttered by the red skull
that's meant to remind you of the
classic indiana jones flick early on in
the movie the red skull finds the
tesseract in a town in norway
avid moviegoers will likely draw the
connection between this line and
hitler's quest to find the ark of the
covenant in raiders
there's a scene in the avengers that
features captain america training at the
gym fury shows up with a briefing and an
invitation to join the avengers
initiative while fury's papers contain
important information it's the name of
the agent who prepared it that makes it
even more fascinating than it already is
at least for comic book fans upon closer
inspection of the first page of the
document the name mephisto is in the
caption under the photo of the tesseract
this codename appears to refer to the
shield operative who helped the agency
acquire data about the powerful artifact
however some might have speculated that
this was a reference to the marvel
comics demon of the same name a
malevolent extra-dimensional force who
uses mystical means and trickery to
cause all sorts of mayhem in the marvel
universe over time mephisto became an
in-joke among mcu fans because of all
the debunked conspiracy theories about
the demon's supposed involvement in the
events of wandavision but hey at least
we can say that the mcu technically does
have a mephisto kinda
during the battle between iron man and
aldrich killian tony lops off killian's
left hand in thor the dark world loki
makes it appear that he chopped off
thor's hand in order to trick the dark
elves in captain america the winter
soldier bucky barnes resurfaces as the
villain with his entire left arm missing
in guardians of the galaxy groot loses
both arms because of gamora while claw
gets his arm swiftly chopped off by
ultron in avengers age of ultron lastly
in ant-man when scott lang disables the
yellow jacket suit with darren cross
still inside it the villain's right arm
shrinks first before the rest of him
does in an interview with cinema blend
kevin feige confirmed that the
phase-wide easter egg was a nod to star
wars episode 5 the empire strikes back
he said it didn't start out as
intentional but it became intentional
in one scene of thor the dark world
there's a chalkboard full of notes from
dr eric selvig and dr jane foster
related to the possible destruction of
earth due to the cosmic event called the
convergence eager fans noticed that the
board contained references to real world
science and thor's comic book lore the
book thor the dark world the art of the
movie released in the same year has a
laymanized list of the items on the
board the chalkboard mentions phenomena
related to black holes how matter
changes from one state to another
electromagnetic forces and even string
theory it also has some terms that comic
readers would doubtlessly recognize such
as 616 universe the nexus of all reality
and the crossroads
simple
any questions
captain america the winter soldier
introduced some significant changes to
the mcu for starters it features bucky
as the winter soldier and contains the
first appearance of the falcon perhaps
most importantly it reveals the sinister
truth behind shield which had become
infested with hydra agents nick fury
even has to fake his own death so he can
continue to work behind the scenes and
bring down the corrupted agency the
biblical passage engraved on his
tombstone ascribed to ezekiel 25 17 will
no doubt be familiar to long time fans
of samuel l jackson it's part of his
dialogue in one of the most iconic
sequences from the famous 1994 crime
film pulp fiction
the path of the righteous man is beset
on all sides by the inequities of the
selfish and the tyranny of evil men in
an interview directors joe and anthony
russo shared that they decided on the
verse following the suggestion of the
film's effects supervisor
for a brief period of time there was
speculation that stan lee would not show
up in guardians of the galaxy due to the
fact that he didn't have a hand in their
creation that's why fans were delighted
when the film's final cut did in fact
contain a cameo from the man himself
complete with his signature line
excelsior flashing on the screen in a
made-up alien language however this was
actually not the original plan for lee's
cameo in an interview with director
james gunn he confirmed that initially
lee was supposed to be a specimen in the
treasure room of the collector and was
supposed to throw a rude gesture at
groot gunn also said that he decided to
scrap the cameo from the film on his own
and that it wasn't a studio mandate as
rumored
avengers age of ultron confirmed what
many audiences probably already knew
about tony stark he had contingency
plans in place if the technology he
frequently relied on ever got disabled
or compromised following the transfer of
his previous ai assistant jarvis into
the body of vision stark was in need of
a replacement stark picks out friday
which becomes his new guidance system
however fans also caught a glimpse of
some of the program cards that stark
didn't select and two of them bore names
that were quite familiar to marvel
comics fans one of the cards was labeled
jocasta which long time readers of the
avengers comic books would know is the
name of the robot that was built by
ultron to be his partner meanwhile
another card bore the name tadashi a
reference to the inventor of the ai
program behind baymax in the disney film
big hero 6.
the organization known as the ten rings
has been an established threat in the
background of the mcu since ironman
however what most fans may not know is
that in 2015 ant-man almost featured a
blink and you'll miss it reference to
the terrorist faction in its final cut
in a commentary track for the film
ant-man lead paul rudd and director
peyton reed spill the beans on a short
scene that was omitted from the movie
after pym technologies ceo darren cross
was able to unlock the shrinking secrets
of pym particles he immediately invited
a group of prospective buyers to a
demonstration at the company in the
deleted scene a tattoo of the 10 rings
was partially visible on the neck of one
of the potential investors implying that
he was actually a member who wanted to
get his hands on the shrinking
technology
during the big showdown between team cap
and team tony at the airport in germany
there's a scene where ant-man and
captain america use pym particles to
turn a shrunken vehicle into an
expanding projectile for a few seconds
we get a glimpse of a unique vehicle
that should be instantly recognizable to
fans of the sitcom arrested development
the bluth company stare car missing the
company's logo on the side there's a
good reason for this easter egg the
russo brothers actually directed the
pilot of arrested development years
before they got into the business of
directing mcu films as fans of the show
would attest the bluth family car wasn't
exactly known for being a smooth ride
and was even used in a few wacky
situations let's just be thankful that
it didn't cause our heroes any trouble
doctor strange featured a simple but
clever gag that was even used in the
film's trailer when steven strange
arrives at the mystical sanctuary in
search of the ancient one her student
mordo hands strange a piece of paper
with the word shambhala on it he asks
what it's for instantly assuming that
it's some sort of magical incantation
mordo's response the wi-fi password
we're not savages
of course because this is a marvel movie
you can bet that there's an interesting
meaning behind the word published in
1986 the 23rd issue of the marvel
graphic novel series features a story
called doctor strange into shambhala the
book follows doctor strange as he
travels to the ancient one's homeland
and eventually arrives at a magical
moral quandary we won't spoil the rest
of the story for you so that you can
read it yourself
when we see stan the man himself in
guardians vol 2 he's wearing a spacesuit
and sitting on an asteroid he's not
alone though as three watchers are
listening to him talk about other
adventures in other words as one twitter
user put it stan lee was canonically a
watcher informant and was playing the
same character in every mcu movie
director james gunn responded to this
tweet by admitting that fan theories on
twitter were what prompted him to shoot
this lighthearted stan lee scene kevin
feige himself acknowledged that the late
marvel legend transcends the reality of
the mcu as cool as it is this scene did
create a bit of a continuity error
though lee mentions being a fedex
delivery man which was his cameo in
captain america civil war a film that
supposedly took place after this one to
his credit gunn acknowledged to the
error there's a scene in spider-man
homecoming where peter parker makes use
of voice-changing stark technology to
sound more intimidating during an
interrogation attempt hilariously it
doesn't work on his target aaron davis
deactivate interrogation mode this
sequence is special for two reasons it
teases the existence of another spider
person and it's the culmination of a
seven year old campaign to put donald
glover in a spider-man movie davis is of
course the uncle of miles morales aka
the spider-man from the ultimate
universe who now occupies the main
marvel earth while the mcu's davis
doesn't say morales name he does mention
that he has a nephew which is more than
enough confirmation back in 2010 when
the spider-man reboot was announced
hashtag donald for spider-man went viral
on twitter as glovers fans pushed for
him to be considered for the lead role
of course andrew garfield was eventually
cast as the webslinger years later
spider-man homecoming director john
watts swore to find a way to include
glover in this spider film and the rest
as they say is history
in thor ragnarok thor finds himself
trapped on the waste planet of sakhar he
becomes an unwilling participant in the
contest of champions the grandmaster
honors previous victors by adding their
sculptures on the tower of his palace
which already has a few familiar faces
on it eagle-eyed fans will have noticed
the faces of the mystical guardian the
man thing the war god ares and the hulk
villains by beast and dark crawler on
the tower the most significant face
there belongs to none other than beta
ray bill a horse-faced genetically
modified member of the corbinite race
and an ally of thor in the comics who
wields the powerful weapon stormbreaker
kevin feige revealed that beta ray bill
originally had a slightly bigger role in
thor ragnarok but he was cut from the
film as he told crave online the feeling
is if you can't do a character like beta
ray bill justice do it later
when t'challa successfully subdues
ulysses claw after a long chase the
villain begs for mercy from the wakandan
king the superhero responds every breath
you take is messy from me it's an
awesome line that unbeknownst to many
moviegoers is actually taken from new
avengers vol 3 number 22 in which
t'challa says it to namor t'challa
already had a major axe to grind with
the arrogant atlantean king before that
issue as namor once caused tremendous
suffering to many wakandans as a result
of what could charitably be called a
petty grudge by the time the two kings
found themselves on the same team their
animosity had already reached a boiling
point leading to a brutal confrontation
and namor's abrupt departure from the
team
while audiences were happy to see
spider-man become formally integrated
into the mcu with the release of
spider-man homecoming the apparent
absence of his famous spider sense
throughout the film became a serious
point of contention in a 2017 interview
with collider spider-man homecoming
director john watts explained the
decision to make the spider sense less
of a presence in his film he said the
idea was again just you want to make
this movie be less about things you've
already seen before and you've
definitely already seen a spider sense
sequence done extremely well in mark
webb's and sam raimi's movies despite
kevin feige's confirmation that the mcu
version of peter definitely possesses a
spider sense and that they would explore
it further down the line fans still
eagerly awaited the day they'd witnessed
this version of the webslinger's spidey
sense in action that day eventually came
in avengers infinity war although aunt
may would eventually refer to it by a
different name please do not start
calling it my peter tingle
while most of ant-man and the wasp
explores scott's life under house arrest
following his participation in the civil
war battle it also introduces another
size changing superhero from the comics
dr bill foster aka goliath the movie
doesn't really show foster engaging in
heroics the same way ant-man and the
wasp do but it does mention his time
working with dr hank pym as a shield
scientist in the scene where dr foster
is shown lecturing to a classroom full
of students the chalkboard behind him is
full of mathematical equations it also
has the word matrix written on it which
while a perfectly appropriate word for
the situation can also be interpreted as
a reference to fishburne's iconic role
as morpheus in the matrix
marvel legend stan lee was able to film
a few extra cameo appearances for a
handful of marvel movies before his
death in 2018. one such easter egg was
for captain marvel during the sequence
where carol danvers searches for a
skrull agent in los angeles she briefly
encounters lee sitting by one of the
windows the comic book writer is shown
reading the script for the 1995 film
mall rats which he also appeared in
speaking to the hollywood reporter mall
rat's director kevin smith expressed his
delight at the nature of lee's cameo and
captain marvel and how it referenced his
film it was really kind of poetic and to
hear him saying his line which to be
fair was some that he would say in real
life all the time trust me true believer
it was everything smith must have been
thrilled by the fact that this was
basically confirmation that a version of
him exists in the mcu
one of the best things about avengers
game is the way the main characters are
able to revisit some of their most
iconic moments in the case of steve
rogers his visit to the past allowed him
to play things a bit smarter in a
situation very similar to that elevator
fight scene from the winter soldier this
time instead of beating up an elevator
full of hydra agents rogers is able to
bypass a violent confrontation
hail andrew
this works and rogers is seen seconds
later exiting the elevator with the
scepter while this scene doubtlessly
calls back to cap's elevator fight it's
also a sly reference to a controversial
2016 comic captain america steve rogers
number one in which rogers is revealed
as a secret hydra agent a move that
unsurprisingly riled fans of the
character that backlash was so fierce
that marvel had to ask for readers to be
patient while the story unfolded
when peter parker was officially
introduced to the mcu in civil war the
character also revealed a bit about his
origin during a candid conversation with
tony stark their talk made it clear that
it was some sort of grave personal
tragedy that served as peter's wake-up
call making him realize that he needs to
fight for the little guy this seemed to
hint at his existence but there was no
formal mention of peter's uncle ben
parker in spider-man homecoming fans
didn't like the omission of arguably the
most important figure in spider-man's
world perhaps that's why the inclusion
of the initials bfp on peter's travel
briefcase in spider-man far from home
was so well received it's the first real
evidence that uncle ben existed in the
mcu as well as a memorable easter egg
black widow gave mcu fans the
opportunity to know more about natasha
romanov's past and adoptive family as
well as what she got up to after the
events of civil war interestingly it
also answered a question that few people
probably bothered to ask how did she get
that cool looking vest as it turns out
the vest belonged to natasha's sister
and fellow black widow operative elena
bilova the younger widow proudly shares
to her big sister whom she has not seen
for more than two decades that the vest
is the first thing she ever bought for
herself after the final showdown the two
sisters say they're loving goodbyes but
not before bulova leaves her vest with
romanov as a parting gift the touching
gesture confirms that the bond between
them remains strong as ever arguably
this also made bulova's reaction to the
news of romanov's death so much more
emotional and believable
in the scene where chongqi and katie
enter the golden daggers club they are
given a quick tour of the place by the
host while most mcu fans will have no
doubt spotted the fight between the
abomination and wong there is another
noteworthy fight featuring two
combatants deeply tied to mcu history in
one of the cells where the fight takes
place a black widow who was rescued
during the events of the black widow
movie is seen squaring off against a
soldier whose body has been enhanced by
the virus from iron man 3. while the
widow appears to get the upper hand by
using her knives she is later seen
tending to the soldier's wounds
reinforcing that not all of the
combatants in the club see each other as
enemies outside of the ring
the second post-credits scene of
eternals sets up the introduction of not
one but two classic marvel heroes after
the disappearance of cersei her beau
dane whitman is seen opening a box
containing what appears to be a family
heirloom a sword that has clearly been
kept wrapped and hidden for a long time
this is of course the ebony blade the
weapon that whitman wields as the
medieval themed superhero the black
knight as the nervous human attempts to
touch the blade he hears a voice saying
sure you're ready for that mr whitman
the scene abruptly ends without
revealing who the mysterious voice
belongs to in an interview with empire
online director chloe zhao confirmed
that the line was spoken by mahershala
ali the mcu's version of blade she said
i gotta say in just the little time i
spent with mahershala i can't wait for
the blade movie to come out
given the sheer amount of nostalgic
references incorporated into spider-man
no way home it's hard to choose the best
among all of its easter eggs for
instance the entire conversation between
the three peters during the climactic
battle is in itself one easter egg after
another the bit where andrew garfield
offers to crack maguire's back to
relieve its stiffness is a clever nod to
maguire's infamous back problems during
the development of spider-man 2. the
filmmakers even managed to sneak in a
scene where the three peters recreate
that famous pointing meme from the 1960s
spider-man cartoon however if we had to
pick just one easter egg as the best of
the lot it would have to be how
garfield's spider-man saves mj from
falling to her death as fans who saw the
amazing spider-man 2 will recall he was
unable to save the love of his life gwen
stacy who died in a strikingly similar
situation it nearly drove him to hang up
the webs for good and by saving the
girlfriend of an alternate reality
version of himself he gained some much
needed closure garfield says a lot with
his face alone in this scene one of the
standout moments in the movie
when doctor strange and america chavez
go multiverse hopping they become
stranded on earth 838 where an alternate
version of strange seemingly sacrificed
his life to defeat thanos however the
traveling duo are detained in the baxter
foundation where the mainstream mcu
strange learns the horrific truth about
his counterparts death here strange also
meets the illuminati a covert group of
heroes who secretly determine the best
course of action against major threats
the illuminati of earth 838 is made up
of mordo captain marvel the inhuman king
black bolt reed richards of the
fantastic four captain carter and their
leader professor charles xavier this
incarnation of professor x sits in his
yellow hover chair from the 90s comics
additionally when he has introduced a
brief segment of the iconic x-men the
animated series theme plays
in one scene of thor love and thunder
zeus uses his godly powers to flick away
a restrained thor's garments he overdoes
it though which leaves thor thoroughly
exposed to the stunned crowd we get a
good view of thor from behind which
shows that he has a big tattoo on his
back to honor his brother loki right
next to it is another tattoo shaped like
a roll of parchment bearing some of the
names of thor's loved ones who have
passed away his mom and dad are there as
are heimdall tony and natasha
interestingly according to director
taiko ytt this easter egg was cut from
thor ragnarok however they deemed it too
good to waste so they made it bigger for
thor love and thunder